[Música]
continúan las manifestaciones a lo largo
de eeuu en contra de la adhesión del
tribunal supremo que anuló el precedente
de 50 años de romper sus web que
reconocía el derecho al aborto
la segunda mayor caravana de emigrantes
de los últimos seis meses se encuentra
en mexico el grupo que partió este
viernes desde tapachula espera los
permisos que les permitan una estancia
de un mes en territorio mexicano aunque
no todos prefieren un legalizar su
estadía y méxico continúa conmocionado
por la violencia contra sacerdotes uno
de los últimos casos fue el de dos
jesuitas que realizaban labores sociales
y fueron asesinados el 20 de junio
tendemos a análisis en esta emisión
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias del continente
americano y santiago ariztía que
comenzamos en eeuu porque desde nueva
york hasta california miles de
activistas anunciaron masivas
manifestaciones para este fin de semana
luego de que el tribunal supremo del
país anulará el precedente de 50 años
del rock versus wire que reconocía el
derecho federal de las mujeres al aborto
el informe de jorge hurtado
el movimiento en defensa del derecho al
aborto se toma las calles al menos en 70
ciudades miles de personas rechazan la
derogación de robert sus way luego que
el tribunal supremo anulara el fallo que
daba el derecho constitucional al aborto
en eeuu
hoy para mí es trágico porque luchamos
mucho para que se aprobara esta ley en
1973 cuando finalmente se consiguió la
victoria ahora 50 años después nos la
han quitado esto está mal está
totalmente mal las mujeres morían por
abortar en aquel entonces estábamos
tratando de proteger los derechos de las
mujeres la vida de las mujeres y ahora
nos han quitado todo starway formas
las senadoras demócratas elizabeth
warren y tim smith pidieron el
presidente yo va a ir en declarar una
emergencia de salud pública para
proteger el acceso al aborto la casa
blanca prevé desafíos legales a las
restricciones de las mujeres que tendrán
que movilizarse a otras ciudades para
aportar
en las multitudinarias protestas que
empezaron el viernes ya se reportan
choques con la policía e incidentes con
grupos antiaborto que salieron a
celebrar la decisión
es un momento muy emocionante para todos
nosotros teníamos 80 personas pro-vida
en una habitación juntas cuando nos
enteramos que la decisión de anular roe
versus wait se había producido y todos
estábamos emocionados y entusiasmados
sabemos que todavía hay que seguir
trabajando y que queda mucho por hacer y
fallo afectaría a 36 millones de mujeres
tras la decisión al menos 6 estados ya
prohibieron el aborto y otros 26 se
preparan para la prohibición en esa
nación solamente 16 estados están a
favor del aborto durante este fin de
semana el país escuchará el rechazo
masivo a una decisión que afectará la
vida de millones de mujeres según varios
organismos de salud incluso más allá de
las fronteras de eeuu
en este contexto activistas y académicos
alertan sobre los efectos que puede
tener la derogación sobre las personas
gestantes afroestadounidenses
condiciones socioeconómicas como la
pobreza y la imposibilidad de acceder a
servicios de salud que se oponían a esta
población en una posición mucho más
vulnerable podrían ampliarse con la
anulación el informe de manuel a cano
un retroceso en los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos que toca especialmente a
las mujeres afroamericanas las alertas
se prenden sobre los efectos que tendrá
la derogación del road versus wave que
acabó con el derecho al aborto en eeuu
sobre las poblaciones más vulnerables
este momento es devastador porque lo que
significa es que en un lugar donde se
tiene la tasa más alta de mortalidad
materna en el país básicamente se está
condenando a las mujeres negras a la
muerte porque ya estamos muriendo en el
parto
las cifras delatan las complicaciones
que podrían derivarse de la anulación
del fallo para las mujeres
afroamericanas antes de la decisión del
máximo tribunal este viernes las mujeres
afroamericanas tenían cerca de 3 veces
más probabilidades de morir por
complicaciones relacionadas al embarazo
y las mujeres en comunidades mayormente
afroamericanas tenían 63 por ciento más
de probabilidades que las mujeres
blancas de experimentar complicaciones
de salud durante el embarazo y el parto
además muchos de los estados en los que
ya se decidió anular el derecho al
aborto la mayoría de las personas que
buscaban estos procedimientos eran
afroamericanas por ejemplo en misisipí
representaban el 74 por ciento las
desigualdades socioeconómicas también
dejan a las mujeres afroamericanas en
una posición más vulnerable una de cada
cinco mujeres negras vive en la pobreza
una cifra que contrasta con las de las
mujeres blancas una de cada diez vive en
dicha condición esto no les permitiría
por ejemplo viajar a otros estados para
realizarse un procedimiento de aborto
estambul sexy giorgi pop o hay un
movimiento para mantener pobres a las
personas pobres
entonces esta decisión realmente resta y
condena a una gran brecha
la anulación del histórico fallo podría
aumentar las desigualdades un estudio de
la universidad de duke del año pasado
mostraba que la prohibición total del
aborto podría aumentar las muertes
maternas afroamericanas en un 33%
estamos con más noticias en france 24 la
segunda mayor caravana migrante de los
últimos seis meses se encuentra en
méxico el grupo que partió este viernes
desde tapachula espera los permisos que
les permitan una estancia de un mes en
territorio mexicano no obstante no todos
prefieren legalizar su estadía ampliamos
en este informe de rafael pérez
en busca de una nueva vida cientos de
integrantes de una caravana migrante
recibieron este sábado visas de tránsito
por parte del instituto nacional de
migración de méxico el grupo integrado
en un principio por unas 3.000 personas
salió este viernes desde tapachula el
principio mexicano fronterizo con
guatemala la mayoría de ellos provienen
de venezuela haití y otras naciones
centroamericanos que nos entregaron el
permiso claro que no nos entregaron a
todos nosotros veníamos en un grupo de
siete y éste a la final nos separaron a
todos nosotros no sabemos dónde están
las otras personas
y bueno esperándome si se pueden
comunicar con nosotros para para ver si
nos podemos juntar otra vez ellos
también que ellos también le den el
permiso
la caravana tuvo que caminar 42
kilómetros hasta una caseta de
inmigración en huixtla allí fueron
atendidos en grupos de 50 personas sin
embargo otros prefieren no pedir el
documento que les permita una estancia
de 30 días en méxico alegan que las
autoridades no lo respetan a iglesias de
hombre porque porque la gran mayoría de
los permiso cuando llegan
corta no lo hacen la mayoría de los
migrantes aún se encuentran tramitando
el permiso de distancia en los últimos
seis meses este es el segundo grupo más
grande que salió caminando hacia eeuu
según la oficina de aduanas y protección
fronteriza estadounidense más de un
millón de personas han sido
interceptadas en su frontera sur desde
octubre del año pasado
y seguimos en mexico pero para hablar
ahora de otra crisis porque el país
sigue conmocionado por la violencia
contra sacerdotes y uno de los últimos
casos fue el de javier campos y joaquín
morados jesuitas que desempeñaban
labores sociales defendían la cultura
local y abogaban por los servicios
básicos en un pueblo en el estado de
chihuahua y fueron asesinados el 20 de
junio entrada 24 diario vamos con el
sacerdote omar sotelo aguilar sobre por
qué los religiosos son blancos de
ataques en mexico y esto nos decía
ciertamente el sacerdocio es un ente
estabilizador social en su comunidad
habla no solo da y ofrece un servicio
espiritual sino que también ayuda a la
migración protege derechos humanos
protege a la familia a los indígenas
todos esos puntos son de alguna otra
manera como bien lo decías un ente que
estorba al crimen organizado porque una
vez que eliminan a un sacerdote
desestabilizan a la comunidad
de estrés y cuidar la comunidad
obviamente en kista la cultura del
silencio del terror la cultura de la
muerte con lo que va creciendo la
narcocultura la narcoeconomía y
lamentablemente la narcopolítica y
también hablamos con omar sotelo aguilar
sobre que debería ocurrir en méxico para
hacer frente a esta problemática de la
violencia contra los sacerdotes
escuchemos lo que nos dijo
yo creo que es lo más importante es
dotar de oportunidades a la gente joven
el crimen organizado tiene recursos
ilimitados recursos económicos y
recursos humanos ilimitados porque
porque la gente joven necesita trabajo
necesita comer está dinero pero ahora su
casa y cuando no lo tienen obviamente
van a eeuu a mí la nota serrato que para
para emigrar a eeuu
hoy mucha gente quiere buscar estos
nuevos lugares pero no legal no
encontrarlos se quedan ahí y entonces
son presa del crimen organizado hay que
acabar entonces con la pobreza que
acabar con todas estas cosas para que de
alguna otra manera los jóvenes tengan
más oportunidades y puedan trabajar
jornada de celebración pero también de
lucha para el colectivo el gmt en las
calles de todo el mundo y es que falta
poco para el día internacional del
orgullo lgtb del 28 de junio y méxico no
fue la excepción bajo el lema la calle
esos son nuestras miles de personas se
movilizaron por la capital del país para
celebrar pero también para continuar
exigiendo el respeto a sus identidades
con estas imágenes nos despedimos sigan
en france 24 y en france mit y
cuatro.com
[Música]